In this video, we're going to
explore how we can start with
acetic acid.
And acetic acid looks
like this.
And end up with acetyl chloride
that looks like this.
And it's going to
be done in the
presence of thionyl chloride.
And thionyl chloride, we haven't
seen it before, but it
just looks like this.
It's a sulfur double bonded
to an oxygen.
And then, it has single bonds
to two separate chlorines.
And then, if you want
to care, sulphur
has six valence electrons.
So it has another lone
pair right over here.
And we'll focus on this.
Because this is really the
simplest reaction of starting
with a carboxylic acid and
forming a acyl halide.
And it can be generalized
very easily.
If you turn this methyl group
into just a larger chain, and
then this will be a larger
chain right here.
And, instead of having a
chlorine here, you could do it
with other halides as well.
So let's think about how
this might occur.
So let's have our acetic
acid right over here.
And then, you have this oxygen
bonded to a hydrogen.
Now, this guy has got
two lone pairs.
And then the thionyl chloride--
I'll redraw the
thionyl chloride right
over here.
And I'll set it up in
the right position.
The thionyl chloride
looks like this.
And this has a lone pair of
electrons right over here.
And all of these molecules,
chlorine, and oxygen-- or all
of these atoms-- chlorine and
oxygen-- we can look at a
periodic table up here.
You see sulphur over here.
And then, to the right of
sulphur is chlorine.
And above sulphur is oxygen.
So both chlorine and
oxygen are more
electronegative than sulfur.
So sulphur is going to have a
partial positive charge there,
even though sulphur is a
reasonably electronegative
atom in its own right.
But these other guys are
going to be sucking
electronic away from it.
So you could imagine this entire
molecule could act as a
nucleophile, with this oxygen,
right over here, giving an
electron to the sulphur.
Sulphur is an electronegative
atom, but it has a partial
positive charge in just
this thionyl cholride.
So it will be attracted there.
And then this guy is going to
have to give up an electron.
And he'll give it back to
this oxygen up there.
And so that will be-- and
this reaction could
go in either direction.
So, once again, I'll draw
it in equilibrium.
But right after that happens,
we'll have this, I guess we
could call it a complex, that
will look like this.
This oxygen, it had
two lone pairs.
It had one pair, two pairs.
And now, it has a third pair,
because it got this electron.
It always had that other
electron in the covalent bond.
And now, it has a
negative charge.
And now, the sulphur is bonded
to those two chlorines.
And then, it is also bonded
to this oxygen over here.
So let me draw it over here.
So we have this oxygen, which
is bonded to this carbonyl
carbon, just like that.
And then, it is bonded to a
hydrogen right over there.
It has one lone pair now.
And the other lone pair is, now,
turned into a covalent
bond with the sulfur.
And so this guy gave
away an electron.
So he now has a positive
charge.
Now, the next step, you could
imagine that this oxygen says,
hey, I liked having a double
bond with the sulfur.
The sulfur is still bonded to
a bunch of things that are
more electronegative to it.
It still has a slightly
positive charge there.
So you could imagine that this
electron gets given back to
the sulfur.
But then, the sulfur needs
to bump an electron.
Chlorine is pretty
electronegative, so one of
these chlorines will be able
to take away an electron.
So this chlorine could take
away an electron.
So then, after that happens,
our situation-- and once
again, this is in equilibrium--
our situation
will look like this.
Let me draw.
So let me draw the original
acetic acid.
Or the part that was part of
the original acetic acid.
And so you have this oxygen,
right over here, bonded to a
hydrogen, bonded to-- let me do
it in the same color so we
can keep track of things--
bonded to this sulphur right
over here, which now has a
double bond, which, now again,
has a double bond with
this oxygen up here.
So I'll do it in that
same color.
It's still bonded to that
chlorine up there.
But now, this chlorine
is left.
It has taken that electron
with it.
So the chlorine had 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6, 7 valence electrons.
It gained this electron,
this orange electron.
So now, it has a negative
charge.
And, by the way, this
guy never lost
his positive charge.
Still has a positive
charge like that.
Now, the chlorine could act
as a nucleophile on
the carbonyl carbon.
This guy is bonded to two
oxygens, more elctronegative,
partially positive charge.
This guy can give an electron
to the carbonyl carbon.
And right as that happens, this
is a nucleophilc attack,
the carbonyl carbon can
give up an electron to
the carbonyl oxygen.
And then, we will be
in equilibrium.
So make sure you realize we're
going to the right then down.
Now, we're going to the
left with this thing.
So this was the carbonyl carbon
bonded to this oxygen
right now, which now, just
took another electron.
So now, it has a negative
charge.
It had 1, 2 lone pairs.
And now, it will have one
more lone pair because
it took that electron.
It always had this
end of that bond.
So now it has both of these
electrons over here.
It has a negative charge.
It gained an electron.
And then, it is bonded it to
this OH group right over here.
And then that is bonded to the
sulfur, which is bonded to the
chlorine, and now double bonded
to that other oxygen.
Of course, we have this chlorine
over here that did
the nucleophilic attack.
So you have this chlorine
over here.
And this nucleophilc attack,
it gave an electron to what
was this carbonyl carbon.
It gave an electron.
So it is now neutral.
And you can kind of imagine that
this negative charge got
transferred to this
oxygen up here.
And this oxygen, right here,
still has a positive charge.
Don't want to forget that.
Now, the next step that could
happen-- once again, all these
can go in either direction-- is
that this guy doesn't like
having a negative charge.
And this guy is still going to
have a partially positive
charge, because he's bonded
to a bunch of more
electronegative atoms
than itself.
So he wants to reform
the double bond.
And that kicks off all of
this business over here.
So then this-- let me do
this in a new color.
I've already used the magenta.
I'll use the pink.
This electron, right here, gets
taken back by this oxygen
that had a positive
charge anyway.
So it would want to
take it back.
And then we are left with-- and
we're getting pretty close
to the punchline.
We are, then, in equilibrium.
This part over here will
then look like this.
We now have reformed
our double bond.
It is only going to
be bonded to the
chlorine, just like this.
And this whole part over here
on the right has broken off.
So you have this oxygen bonded--
let me do it in the
same colors.
You have this oxygen bonded
to a hydrogen.
It now gained an electron.
So it is now neutral.
And it is bonded
to this sulfur.
The sulphur is in green.
It's bonded to the sulfur, which
is bonded to a chlorine.
And then, it has a double
bond to this
oxygen right over here.
So we've already formed
our acetyl chloride.
And we've really finished with
the hard part of the
reaction-- to see that how you
could get an acetyl chloride.
And then to kind of complete
this reaction-- because if you
actually perform this in a
beaker, you'll end up with
some hydrogen chloride and
some sulfur oxide as a
by-product.
You could imagine that this
oxygen, right over here, takes
back its electron from
this proton,
gives it to this sulfur.
And then, the sulfur, since it
got an electron, will allow
the electronegative chlorine
to take back its electron.
And then, if we just focus on
this, the acetyl chloride, at
this point, isn't doing
anything anymore.
This would be in equilibrium
with something
that looks like this.
You now have a hydrogen proton
floating around.
Just a naked proton, really.
There's not even any
neutrons there.
You have this oxygen,
which is now double
bonded with this sulfur.
So I'm going to try to keep all
of the colors the same.
This, right here, was yellow.
And then, that original bond
it had with it was magenta.
And then, you have the chlorine
nabbed that electron.
And it already had seven
valence electrons.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7. it now
has a negative charge.
And then, the final step.
So we already have our
sulphur dioxide.
Now, the final step is just the
chlorine giving one of its
electrons to the hydrogen to
form hydrogen chloride.
So then, the final step
is just this.
So when all is said and
done, we end up
with some acetyl chloride.
We end up with some
hydrogen chloride.
And we end up with
sulphur dioxide.
Just like that, and
we're done.
And, once again, you can
generalize this to get it
starting with any carboxylic
acid and forming the acyl
halide version of it, or acyl
chloride version, if you want
to stick with a chloride
right over here.
Actually, this, right here,
is acetyl chloride.
Anyway, hopefully, you found
that entertaining.